comment
oh
[Musique]
pour les fans de l'émission difficile
aujourd'hui de dissocier vincent vinel
de lose yourself le 18 février il tente
l'aventuré the voice et cartonne avec le
titre d' eminem laventure sauvé ça se
passe plutôt bien jusque là j'ai
l'impression
plein de bonnes rencontres des moments
musicaux c'est top
ça fait super plaisir d'avoir le coup de
projecteur sur soi et en même temps
voilà ça nous permet de nous exprimer de
pouvoir transmettre la passion de la
musique qui est je pense que c'est
important de pouvoir la transmettre avec
un maximum de personnes parce que
musique c'était pour partager
mal voyant de naissance vincent vinel à
seulement la vingtaine et l'oreille
absolue
celui qu'on surnomme le héros de la gare
saint lazare est originaire des
clayes-sous-bois il était de retour dans
sa commune pour un showcase
il sent bien il est super gentil vincent
une voix extraordinaire il fait passer
des émotions
à tence aussi bien premier point que
vous moi même et à ma femme
sa simplicité son talon et puis plein
d'énergie il y avait un talent fou c'est
un chanteur et musicien depuis toujours
il dit que pour ça depuis qu'il est tout
petit il vit que pour la musique mais je
m'attendais pas à ce que les gens
ressentent sa musique de cette manière
et soit aussi enthousiaste du côté du
télé crochet vincent continue l'aventuré
dans l'équipe du chanteur mika samedi
dernier s'est qualifiée pour les tirer
[Musique]